this guy looks like christian at 45
years
[Laughter]
[Music]
you know what i don't like is you visit
the ufc institute was it the ap what
they call it what's that [ __ ] it's
called the apex the apex and you're
acting all different you came in they're
all tough ap burning gives up halfway
through a word you know
i don't know what they call api center
apex
apex predator center dude you're part of
the problem you went there and you're
acting all different what are you
talking about you went there they gave
you a black belt now all of a sudden
you're a black honorary black belt i
went in there man uh they gave me a
black belt but it was just because you
had to look a certain way in there the
black cells not a black belt a black
belt yeah it was a dress code different
yeah it was a clip-on belt too well
that's weird it's not keeping anything
it's just a front yeah a facade yeah a
facade belt and you've never been to the
apex dude i've never been over there
it's called the apex center yeah that's
why yeah
apex predator that's [ __ ] it's weird
right relax you're already the guy
you're already the dudes everyone's cool
yeah dude it was crazy in there they had
um
yeah i went over there and they
ended up making it up dude
what did they have yes
saying this dude they're not dude
you're remembering it sounds like it
sounds awfully like the beginnings of
making it up
this is still and uh
i can't remember as fast as other people
hey
it doesn't work though
it's hard to remember like dude if you
ever tried to close your eyes and think
of what you're wearing it's really
[ __ ] hard it's tough it's hard that's
my word
yeah like what pants do you have on yeah
yeah you look like
that's a look
the way you give up halfway through
words bro he does
yeah you'll be
if you ask him about anything he'll
cheat he he cheats sometimes
you got you got that oh what are you
doing hey were you there for them to
scan your brain
yeah
um i just went over there just to meet
with ufc just to see what it was like i
got to go on a tour the facilities bro
after all the tweeting you've done
during the pay-per-views it's finally
paid off you finally got the recognition
you deserve so wait you you went they
just wanted to meet what was cool yeah i
just wanted to meet i just sounds like
someone's trying to [ __ ] yeah step in
for neil darius that's what they were
talking about yeah
it's bobby green
yeah no way didn't bobby green just
fight yeah and he won
against the mag chef yeah soon oh my
gosh
it's like minus twelve guy in good shape
though that's why they could have put me
in dude yeah you went in there and they
just had like uh yeah i mean it's just
exciting i mean
um i got to go in the gym where all the
guys you've been in there where all you
guys train or where they do like video
shoots and stuff before the guys train
yeah then before the therapy thing where
you guys are hurt they had a guy in
there in a wetsuit just dripping just
from the hero done yeah getting ready
for a fight yeah just burning off they
had some other guy just taping his arms
up
um
what else
you saw dana yeah dude
bro he came in the room i'm sitting in
there that's when you met him you hadn't
met him i met him before oh you have
okay yeah yeah
it's almost like
um like a big like um
almost like a snowman kind of you know
kind of like like a snowman but that
went to like a uh
like a snow gym um oh a lot of snow
involved yeah yeah but just not to a
snowman just sitting in the yard getting
fat and drinking it was like a snowman
that's like oh you're describing santa
yeah
with no gifts no gifts right yeah it
just came in just money yeah
no you remind you of like king pin off
of spiderman like suit ball head yeah
like kind of like if gru had like a
strong like more athletic brother maybe
like yeah if gru was on trt
yeah yeah yeah maybe brew is just from
despicable me oh yeah i have a kid i
have a kid but he hasn't watched one
dude we're trying to catch up man we
just saw fern garlic you got to start
early
also known as an avatar stole the plot
really same blue
wow think about it you're a conspiracy
theory no not at all you are those are
facts but okay but you're a conspiracy
theorist also maybe if that doesn't have
to do with this you are a conspiracy
theory yeah and he just shook my hand
his business
some of his
employees and business partners were in
there
this guy
um are they are you the next cm punk are
they trying to convince you to take wow
dude how amazing would it be if you
trained and you got in the octagon dude
theo
uh how i don't think i could get in the
octagon i think i could get in some
regional or semi-region no wait you
could if it was me and you
no
i could that's what i'm thinking bro
what if that came in we're looking for
an opponent for jake paul you're in theo
let's do the thing about jake paul
all the best boxers have come from like
regions of like hardship right and and
like the worst cities and [ __ ] yep and
jake paul has come from the worst like
online hater shaming [ __ ] yeah right
that's just one of his women's monsters
it's turning into this monster it's got
that inside you know he's a rich kid
just put a chip on him from the gutter
yeah
well i think um
yeah i don't have anything but uh that
was that good insight that i had that
was legit you wanna you should say it on
shout out you could say like yeah i'm
like you know chris he will say this
i'll take it as mine you can you can
thank you but yeah dude i just enjoyed
it it was good yeah i just got so
excited i mean i i just i realized last
year it's my favorite sport yeah you've
been a fan of it for about six weeks now
what was you what was your favorite wait
hold on what was your favorite sport
before nfl football right
i didn't assume cfl no by the way cfl is
my favorite sport and i don't mind cfl
yeah no ricky ray [ __ ] look up ricky ray
is that canada yeah oh dude no
why why is canadian but oh because the
rules are different because you've
you're friendly way up north have you
gone way up north those dudes are bigger
than you yeah they're monsters they're
monsters why is that not the most
competitive football the fact that
that's not the most competitive football
way way way you know why yeah well black
guys
okay fair enough
that's a guy in the [ __ ] thing dude
yeah his hair this is amazing bro he's
like the most athletic youth pastor in
america but up there he's a quarterback
dude and they have to they have to get
the cash before you can tackle in canada
so it's like are we cool yeah and then
they apologize yeah and then apologize
so friendly sorry
yeah they just they don't have the same
athlete so it's you know it's just like
the wnba no black guys they don't have
anybody but they have the slowest twitch
muscles you need fast twitch muscles man
yeah if i want to watch all white guys
play football i watch cfl yeah that guy
but that guy's hair is in the nfl that's
right it's not there anymore he's like
they went downtown god what a reference
he's got great hair but then his hair
his hair is gone now 60 000 passing
yards in the cfl
yeah they're good it's a 40-yard field i
don't know is that is that a lot for cfl
because all they do really is pass
i think because they're scared
they don't hurt until like 15 years they
don't want to hit that we have to play i
remember i used to work at this place we
had a place in our town called was it
garden dining or something somebody
opened up a salad-only
restaurant night time called garden
dining right are you serious
yeah they sound awful so you're 24-hour
salad joint you want to go to a [ __ ]
late-night salad
place yeah hey get out of the bar
anybody else feeling a house
oh man you know what i could go for some
[ __ ] raspberry vinaigrette
at the bar hey man you know what i'm
jonesing for a caesar salad you think
we're not doing that at the same time
no nobody's ever done that bad business
plan
you guys have a limited freaking
ability to
envision
different this
is idea tonight you are like a black
pastor right now you're talking like a
black pastor these are so many words
that and you're getting to what you mean
but you don't really mean anything
that's what a black pastor does and you
know that i want to talk about this
other place but what you're doing is
ebenezer
what you're doing all right they're just
naming people aren't even in the bible
ebenezer scrooge
came down
and there's always that [ __ ] that one
guy's just yelling he's not gay what's
that thing you always do i'm not gay
anymore oh yeah that dude i don't like
men's anymore oh i love a women hello
i'm not gonna carry a purse no more he
didn't even know how to pluralize women
i love a women's that's what he said
dude
that's how gay he was i follow that guy
on instagram
he's awesome yeah but he knows it now he
wears hats that are like cakes bro he's
unbelievable yeah
he's live on his instagram andreas he's
living this truth oh he's killing it
yeah oh he's good for him and did he
beat it or is he still did he no he's in
the physical game even more he's the
fifth round
he's in the fifth round because doesn't
he have a he posts about his girlfriend
right was he oh i thought he was more
gay now no i know used to like used to
post about his girlfriend like a year
ago and he had a girlfriend we're like
but you know what it is i want to get
back to the salad place but you know
what this you know what it is you go so
hard in one direction that all of a
sudden you all you got to do is just
open that door peek out and there you
realize like if you go so hard not gay
not gay i'm not gay i'm not gay i'm not
gay [ __ ] this i'm not getting tattoos
i'm not gay
i hate gay people you get all this
hatred in your heart all you gotta do is
just [ __ ] prop that door open there
it is and you're sucking dick you know
what i mean yeah i guess that's what it
is dude you're right there it's about
that circle you start here no the the
most not gay and then you go over and
then and then there you are gay gay okay
it's a loop it's not a line not gay to
the most gay it's a circle not gay to
the most gay boom right here
same thing dude it's a loop yeah it's a
loop it could be a [ __ ] video but
this salad place
oh so go back to this because
yeah uh yeah it was just like a kind of
like a strip mall venture that some
people started but
we would go there after the football
after the football game some of us would
go over there an all solid place huh
yeah it was all salad you boys were just
trying to get in like summer shape like
cowboy summer no like why is all a bunch
of men's eating salads it was a new
place that had come into town i think
people were excited you know who's this
place called chicks worked over there
super salad garden dining
that's also a horrible name yeah i mean
garden dining i don't i we like to i
mean i didn't yeah but how long how many
times did you go probably five four four
or five after every game that was their
spot yeah after how many games are there
way more than four or five it wasn't his
10 in a season but five are away so four
at home they went every game every home
game to celebrate i like that we figured
it out but okay so they had a couple
chicks that worked over there too well
of course they did no men are gonna work
at an only seventh place except for
anderson caldwell
but the question i have is uh how long
was it in operation then not long we
know not long right i would say that
season yeah just that season no probably
eight uh no i would say probably
12 to 14 months okay okay and where was
this place it was in a like a strip mall
uh
pretty much a strip mall but what's what
city though oh this is in uh covington
louisiana or mandeville louisiana crazy
that a salad only place would be in
louisiana when with all the fried foods
yeah
oh people some
[Laughter]
yeah yeah
let's take a little break from king the
sting and the wing cause the new year is
here it's 2022 man there's no better way
to kick off this year than by making
sure you're feeling your absolute best
man maybe he drank a little too much
last night maybe you're dehydrated from
working out in the gym maybe you just
don't feel great i'm telling you man a
lot of it has to do with your hydration
that's why one stick of liquid iv in 16
ounce of water hydrates faster
more efficient efficiently than water
alone liquid iv has incredible hydration
flavors like watermelon my favorite
lemon lime strawberry pina colada and so
much more one stick again of liquid iv
in 16 knots of water hydrates better
than water alone contains five essential
vitamins b3 b5 b6 b12 vitamin c
three times electrolytes of any of those
fancy sports drinks all right
it's fantastic man liquid iv is also on
a mission to change the world liquid iv
has donated over 19 million servings
globally worldwide kids grab liquid iv
in bulk nationwide at costco or get 25
off when you go to liquid iv.com use the
code kats at checkout that's 25 off
anything you order when you use the
promo code kats at liquidity.com
experience better hydration today at
liquidity.com promo code cats a lot of
you listeners and viewers out there are
busy man you got kids you got girls you
got mans you got cats you got dogs
you're not trying to leave the house
maybe you're cooking a meal you forgot
one ingredient like what am i gonna do i
can't leave the stove or maybe you're a
podcast or maybe you're binge watching
your favorite show you're like i'm not
trying to leave i'm in my undies what am
i gonna do i got you man grubhub they
now deliver all your go-to convenience
items all day long through their own
convenience store grubhub goods
whether it's a late night snack
paper towels one can of soda you need
your drinkies your snackies all right we
got you delivered right to your door
just in the nick of time so you never
have to leave your crib order
convenience items from grubhub goods on
the app or online grubhub but i don't
know what what interesting restaurants
did they have by you guys growing up
that's a good question um
well okay
this is new jersey oh new jersey when
you're in new jersey there's some good
restaurants jersey yeah oh yeah well
diners galore like [ __ ] garden dining
forget it dude new jersey dude the
diners in new jersey i wish in la they'd
open up some [ __ ] diners dude yeah
they're like they're all shut down
thanks
yeah so they're all shut down but there
were even like two or three before that
and then now they're only open till like
11. but new jersey's got these 24-hour
diners that just the menus are like you
need a bookmark it's like john grisham
wrote the [ __ ] thing yeah cheesecake
cage after pizza it's like cheesecake it
makes cheesecake look like a [ __ ]
pamphlet oh yeah it's page after page
after picture like john gruden's
murderer always
you could get [ __ ] hats and [ __ ] just
like it's unbelievable like i get the
recipe sandwich and yeah let me buy a
few remote controls you know what i mean
like they just have everything it's
unbelievable and it's all banging dude
it's
yeah and some of them
not the fish
it's always battered fish yeah and uh
and also some of the menus even have um
i was at a place one time where the
menus had um
a little battery power thing on the back
and it would like
yeah that's lit
that's lit though it's kind of cool
people loved it yeah i've been
especially as a kid i've been into it we
had a place i don't know if it's out
here gunther tooties have you guys heard
no that's not it that's not it that's
right
i don't know if it's still there but you
know the scene from pulp fiction where
they're dancing and it's like of course
i do
it's that it's like an old school 50s
diner whole festival was actually one of
the shakes that they had at the uh
garden dining i think because it was
like uh
it was like pulp from oranges well it
was yeah i was like all of it was like
uh health based so anyway go on yeah
no i'm telling you and and i don't know
why my mom would do this would be a very
special occasion we go there and they
had uh coca-cola and you get like
chocolate coca-cola or vanilla and put
vanilla syrup and they had shakes i used
to just get all them it's like hey mom
now as a parent don't let me drink six
of them you know what i'm saying
but it was
y'all would go at a special time yeah
birthday
you know oh okay gunther tutti was a cop
in a 19 uh yeah what carpet where are
you yeah brandon knows that movie
because it's a movie
i'm telling the place was sick and you
sit in like everything was like old
school like corvette oh wow like it was
like you know those red seats like a car
yeah i like that historical venues yeah
seems good american food with the 50s
vibes yeah i like that man and they have
like uh
they have something at disneyland where
they also have that really yeah oh
that's right of course they do
you can say that without even knowing
fact but know that it's there yeah do
you know what i mean like that's of
course they do well they have like a
diner they're like a 50s yeah yeah yeah
yeah but i'm saying even though if you
don't know that 100 percent disney has
everything but disney but what about in
rome do you think they have a 50s diner
in rome
oh no
they've also never changed rome didn't
have the fifties wrong they skipped rome
still has the likes like ancient rome
and then today yeah and by the way
there's no between what about the 10 a.d
diner over in rome you know
medieval times i had something funny i
was going to say i was going to do a
joke and the moment passed and you
started talking about medieval times
and the rage i felt was just insane i'm
so sorry no it's fine it's not even here
but you gotta go i know i know i missed
it it's my fault the pool's warm it's my
fault but the pool's warm
jumping i i know and i'm gonna jump in
and as is
i'm in i'm wet i'm already in i'm wet
but i missed the opportunity and it's
fine and now i don't even remember what
i was gonna say but let's get to what
you're saying medieval times who's been
in me of course i have of course i don't
know dude dana white would beat
everybody admitted evil times
i've been there i've been here it's
pretty lit it's cool but after after 30
minutes like all right let's go look if
you guys are done being [ __ ] dude
yeah let's just jeremy renner sent a
video no no that's orlando bloom okay
yeah
what's up king of the sting it's awesome
here in nebraska i'm coming at you today
with a new segment proposal uh let me
tell you a story uh 20 years old uh
forklift operator made a couple bad
decisions eight houses on fire dropped
about 3 600 pounds of steel on my foot
steel toe boots
chopped off my half my foot um so i'm
coming to you with the freak show uh
anyone that has any amputations
uh
deformities mutations whatever [ __ ] you
want to call it uh call in you know give
us a little story about your life uh me
you know
during recovery uh king the sting and
fighter and the kid uh
this past weekend all kind of played a
huge part he didn't name your show
residual depression that came with that
so uh he used to listen to my show
gang gang buzz
show show the stump doggy here we go oh
wow that's a tattoo oh wow that's weird
too i just see it oh
oh
cute um did that puerto rican girlfriend
that's sick uh dude do you know there
was a nfl kicker who had a stub like
that i think it's kind of cheating
because he would have a steal tom nelson
for the new orleans 63-yarder
dude we need to get off the screen
for that reference he'd have to [ __ ]
steal boot and then boom just [ __ ]
kick back
cheating a little bit well here's the
problem with a steel boot okay you've
been smoking
oh i've been vaping a little okay here's
the problem with a steel boot is that if
something too much heavy falls on it
this steel actually then clamps down
and is
more
worse dude name a more out of shape
kicker and go huh
dempsey's worse was sebastian monster
well how do you know about the steel how
do you know about that because it just
makes sense
it's science i thought that it's science
so so so you can't just because
something makes sense you don't mean you
could start it out by saying
here's the thing because it might not be
the thing but that was yeah but what you
do is you sell us some [ __ ] that is true
and that it might or might not be the
thing that's cause he's cause he's a
cult leader right he's just trying to
get us to jump in your goddamn cold no
he thinks he wants to think he's a
wizard he's a czar dude he's resorted
that's the truth but he starts over here
he's like you know what i think about
jingle bells is that the thing is that
you know it you don't know if it's
christmas or not yes but you're sitting
there [ __ ] opening again yeah yeah
they say you know you're buying a life
rips hoodie and [ __ ] for no reason god
or rife rips did you see those i didn't
know i don't know if that's true or not
but that right did those oh wow
hopefully not um i'll say this man i
think you got a k if you only have oh
could you date a could you date a girl
with like one arm like the shark they
got real one time in a um
i knew it off of santa monica boulevard
there we go she had a so part of her
legs she didn't have any cartilage in
her ankle or that's not bad she didn't
have so her foot she had a really good
credit for the amputee yeah dude i'm
talking no legs no arms daddy maybe you
don't have a she was missing a achilles
heel dude
i dated girl yeah i hooked up with a
girl that sprang to ankle it's not the
same [ __ ] i can't finish my story this
guy picks us up in the uber pool of
[ __ ] on every story
you go on a 40-minute ride with this guy
i'm trying to tell you a good story
about someone who's struggled
so this lady she had a thing on the back
of her foot that kept this part and this
part kept it facing like a foot
otherwise it would just
droop down so she had she had a limp
limp leg i had no idea we go out to eat
we're having a nice time how would you
we go back to her motel or hotel
she takes this thing off right okay
slings it like this
breaks the [ __ ] window in the hotel
room
how does this [ __ ] like how is this
happening to you is that some weird but
all these things like what is it with
you it's look at you yeah i understand
but
you don't just say
no i get it but like what is all this
weird [ __ ] what are you talking about
what happened to you i don't even mean
it's
look at this
first of all his foot always his foot's
lit out the side dude doesn't have arms
and his legs and somehow he's still
slightly more attractive than nick
okay let's [ __ ] put that together i'm
just joking
but i had to say that i just didn't know
what
this guy looks like christian at 45
years old
same height
[Laughter]
why did
it's he's i don't know if he's heard
them all but you know it's like oh yeah
he probably approached that he's hurt
y'all are going to hell dude
can you [ __ ] surf no look at him
no i can't surf honestly i ca but he
can't surf the net
[Laughter]
y'all going to hades brother
he's going to stop he was doing it
you can't say that and expect me not to
say that i don't i was trying to
i'm saying it's [ __ ] dope we can surf
and you [ __ ] can't man not the
getting rid nets a shark's not gonna
attack
a shark would definitely go after no no
no no because he's like a seal
shark's like all right no limbs
what about how did you see the shark get
eat the [ __ ] bro yeah you know shark
week how they're like oh they don't like
the taste of humans [ __ ] off dude you
watch this homeboy swimming and you know
how in shark week they always show the
shark in slow motion grab the seal out
of the water like this
homeboy human yeah i know you already
know yo you've
australian thing ever to happen by the
way with especially with the dude
someone just got eaten by shark
oh my god his video skills are off
oh no no stop please no
oh no vietnam is happening
[Music]
dude he thought somebody should do
something
oh you know what are you gonna do
i'm not i'm not
i ain't biting me in anymore yeah yeah
yeah
that sharks i don't like a human
dude he uh that who is that commentator
[Laughter]
that's terrifying dude they say sharks
don't like the taste of human but what
the [ __ ] oh yeah what shark told you
that yeah yeah but also i heard that
shark go yum afterwards so
you got anybody say got any more mm-hmm
that ain't garden dining brother i'll
tell you that that's far from it daddy
that's that's on my diet carnival sea
diet i'm a great white diet i want you
to stop the great white diet not eating
humans
the great white diet sounds real racist
dude
it definitely does
it definitely does yeah all right what
do you got nick uh so this is actually a
segment chris hasn't done yet um people
anonymously send in confessions of
things they want to get off their chests
it's pretty interesting
and uh this is the first one
my favorite part is them trying to stay
anonymous
to 2004 when blockbuster was a thing
i used to play games or movies i already
had that i did that didn't work
and
keep theirs
and return mine
is someone tickling him they started
putting a barcode on the actual disk
what i
see a prisoner in north korea in my 40
games
and rent
for 8.99
a new game
gang gang
buzzfeed what what did he say 1999 2002
he returned 40 damage games to
blockbuster like his game was all [ __ ]
up he'd take the the new game that
worked and give them the games that
didn't raise my heart wait why why is
that's a hustle well okay it's a hustle
but why does he have so many damage to
video games yeah
[Music]
use them as [ __ ] door stops i don't
understand i think you probably live in
a i would guess like a flood plain or
something that affected a lot of stuff
at once oh you're a detective maybe you
lived in like a dirt you are you're a
detective that's good that's good to
know to know to figure that out did you
just go to the last blockbuster oh
thanks yeah it is go to like where it's
in oregon right it's in bend oregon [ __ ]
yeah i knew that [ __ ] and it's still
popping bro no joke i pull up
there's a guy
walking up to the night drop and
dropping his videos in there amazing you
go inside it's all the same it's like it
looks just like the like the k like the
counter kind of curves there's two
people standing there like taking the
little thing off of the thing and
putting it on the thing or whatever
they're doing yeah like they got their
duties they're still scanning it into
the old computers
it's absolutely insane are they still
charging people for late charges and
[ __ ] um i'm sure they probably are and
the cool thing is they have all the
different sections like uh do they have
new movies or that guy rented like tango
and cash i didn't see what the guy
rented i did say i thought he was you
can rent movies there yeah yes
it's functioning oh i thought it was
like a a museum or something or an
archive now there is a place you could
do a birthday party for children or
adults in there i would do it 100 bro i
remember blockbuster we would always
return it late my mom would always
negotiate with the guy like dude you're
like 300 in late fees mom like i know we
just forgot so anyway just let's get
this one i'll pay next time she never
paid really never
and then they went out of business yeah
well creeps like you guys and this guy
killed the company then
for sure what did so what so this guy's
admitting this and then what do we do
we're just saying like oh yeah you're an
awful guy no we tracked him down and
killed him oh wow a little bit he's just
getting it off his chest yeah he feels
better nah bro uh-uh you eat that [ __ ]
you did it you eat it i think you call
the go to the last blockbuster making
amends yeah return all those [ __ ] 40
games dude people should go the last
blockbuster and make an amends for all
the [ __ ] that they how they screwed over
blockbuster that sounds like a good bro
i used to i used to rent twisted metal
oh dude it's every two once every two
weeks buy it it's a video game yeah i
didn't have to yeah you didn't have the
money if you were renting it every two
weeks my mom would write fake checks be
cool man okay so that game was so
[ __ ] dope twice twisted metal and
what is it tell me more about it twice
did metal was the best
it would you well go ahead go ahead
mm-hmm
he can't do it no i can't the best was
there was a there was like an ice cream
truck with machine guns on it yeah and a
clown drove it you it was just damaged
it was basically demolition derby but
with like guns needed for speed but with
guns but there's no racing right no no
no no race
here we go right here but i liked uh
twisted metal was so [ __ ] lit why
don't they bring it back they tried to
they tried to i think that they went
through something they were going to
bring it back and then like something
legally
no or they said let's do another grand
theft auto yeah maybe i loved this
[ __ ] game god that was my wow i never
saw this i was always the semi-truck
it was very successful but it wasn't
like in the lexicon in a way
no it wasn't like sonic the hedgehog but
it was like if you knew
graphics terrible should we play this on
an episode we should yeah wonder what
game i played what'd you play i don't
remember you don't remember like uh
i remember contra or like i remember did
you know the code up down there left
right left right a b a b
start unlimited lives yeah oh yeah i do
okay yeah we knew that all right i
didn't know okay but you knew we knew
that so wait so twisted metals
was awesome that's true i like the
perfect dark better than golden eye
remember a perfect dark do you remember
that i don't remember let me tell you
what perfect dark it was so after
goldeneye they wanted to make another
james bond video game but they lost the
licensing like the multiplayer like it
same thing okay but just the next
generation they couldn't do it because
of the licensing of the 007 so they made
perfect dark which was the same game but
you were a woman that would and it was
just a better version of that i know i
get it but bro but if you're there awoke
back then it wasn't a thing it was just
like it was it sounds racist it was
before woke but yeah perfect dark it was
before
it was more like uh to
be attractive to like weird gamers
having this oh
but what about roger rabbit the video
game that game great games kind of games
making me sad who played ollie who
played odd world in here that was the
guys that makes me never heard of that
odd world
you'd push a button he'd fart bro
nothing makes me more sad than
unsuccessful video games that came out
in the 90s that's so weird that [ __ ]
that feeling of like how it's not good
and the and the way the art is and it
just doesn't quite click it's just like
look at this [ __ ]
oh that game was great
no i'm saying double dragon was lit as
[ __ ] wow this stuff brings me back me
too dude you my brother were so into it
this game was so hard bro dude that
looks like a seat well it's too hard we
stopped playing it it looks like water
is hard yeah why is it driving it's a
road dude well some things something
that must be the tough thing about a
game how do you make a game where it's
hard enough
but it's not too hard now every game
seems like this as long as you have it
for a week and a half you can beat it
yeah that's what every game seems like
now i feel like there's my son just got
mario kart the new there's like mario
kart like five super mario kart and does
he do good at it yeah wow
but it's on the nintendo switch so the
graphics are way better
split what is that anybody play the
barbie game no no because i'm not a gay
man
yeah of course not of course yeah but of
course not that i played this game
recently called cuphead
it's the hardest game i've ever played
in my life it it's maddening you i was i
was losing my mind but the artwork on
this game is so funny oh
i did see this so cool as an option to
buy from my son no he you can't play it
i mean look how hard it is oh my god the
graphics are nuts it's awesome dude
it's kind of awesome they're also real
old-school looking yeah well that's what
i like though dude anybody [ __ ] with
angry birds
not really i'm addicted to it dude look
how hard this is now yeah i had to take
it off my phone i found myself playing
it so much wow that's stupid i'm on
level 700. yeah but that my son's on
level 40. and i talk [ __ ] to him
well i guess that's good right yeah i
actually donate money i'll give it money
so i can get more lives and carry on
with jewels i'm trying to think about
whatever game i really liked what i hate
is there were games i played that i
can't even remember yeah well yeah you
know what i'm saying it's like we played
guys
you have to go rent games yeah yeah dude
nfl blitz anybody had yeah stewart on
the front cover nfl
steward of legends nba
stop that no i'm not saying no he's you
don't you know who started that homeboy
sort of what chris started that uh no
not chris the the the guy who's now
apparently came out as gay frank i don't
like ben's anymore
he said cordell stewart is gay really
university caller alumni someone defends
the death he sued him in one court of
stuart's married with kids he started
that rumor he sued uh like a women's
yeah really yeah really yep
why did that guy why did that guy say
that guy at cordova store was gay i
don't know
but he got sued defamation of character
jerry olshans guys have a girl shansky
jersey i'll say this dude there was the
people was getting blown jobs in shinley
park over there yeah but cordell wasn't
there i'm not saying he was but
here's the problem is everybody in
pittsburgh wears a jersey
so that's one of the issues you run into
dude oh it could be a homeless dude it's
a terry bradshaw jersey oh it could be a
homeless woman
yeah
i told you brendan yeah why you sit over
there
let's take another little break man
we'll get right back to the show the
king the sting in the wing because
listen if there's one thing every
fighter knows it's that you never step
in the ring unless you're 100 ready to
go and always watch out for the sucker
punch the same thing applies to
investing i know that's a fight
reference and that's probably why they
wrote that because they used to fight if
you didn't know that but let's guess
what man last month stock in crypto
markets sucker punch all this right in
the tummy yep but not me because i got
masterworks in my corner that's right
they help normal guys like you and me
diversify their portfolios with blue
chip art from masters like picasso all
right and diversifying with art isn't
new the ultra wealthy i've done it
forever
all right so join over 330 000 members
get priority access to masterworks with
this unique link go to masterworks
dot art slash kats that's masterworks
dot art slash k-a-t-s
see important disclosure that massworks
dot io slash disclaimer masterworks dot
art slash kate ats fellas you know when
you're raring to go with your lady or
your mans whatever you're into i don't
care man but you gotta be ready you
gotta be just not ready gotta be roman
ready roman ready all right
um you need roman to get roaming all
right go to get roman.com kats right now
to speak with the u.s licensed
healthcare professional about erectile
dysfunction you get 15 off your first
month of treatment also e.d if you're
suffering from it dude
don't be worried man 50 of bros between
the ages of 40 to 70 will experience
some form of ed all right and listen
your partner's gonna thank you man and
another thing you don't need to be all
self-conscious about it because it's
confidential totally discreet all right
there's no giant logos on the box that
say dick pills all right you have to
worry about that
um getting started is simple just go to
getroman.com kats complete an online
visit take care of your ed without
leaving your crib complete an online
visit today to connect with a u.s
licensed healthcare professional and
take care of it go to getroman.com
kats today if you're prescribed you get
15 off your first month of ed treatment
make sure you're ready to have
confidence and control this fall roman
ready
that's what you get when you're not that
good it gives up on you you don't you
don't rock any jersey
you don't rock any jerseys ever i don't
talk so much [ __ ] about me
yeah let's get him he's out here
look at him dude he can't do anything
come on guys i feel bad right now hey
your mom didn't give you any lunch money
today huh kid
[ __ ] yeah
yeah
do you did you have you obviously you
had a nintendo super nintendo do you
have like the sega genesis
goddamn
shin come on i just built this i'll give
him a minute i'll give him a minute
first [ __ ] get over there
i'll look out here watching him do it
because you know how to do it
i like how meatballs trying to get
involved yeah look at this
yeah good work man
nice dude thanks guys and we're back and
we're back should we talk about the the
thing should we tell the thing the the
thing coming up for us oh how you can
only watch theo chris
and and the thick boy on patreon uh-huh
yep we really should talk about it for
two episodes a month we'll be on patreon
two episodes a month we got patreon yeah
yeah go break it down no big deal the
new goal is to do two episodes a month
on patreon nick with just us three with
the new uh title king of the sting kings
the sting and the wing that's right
we'll have a new set it's gonna be
popping yep why the shoot after this why
the wing why do you call yourself the
wing eagle the eagle thing yeah yeah
yeah so
so uh yeah it's gonna be like that and
there's gonna be two episodes on patreon
and two episodes not on patreon on
youtube two will still be free available
on the king of the sting youtube and
then the other two with just the three
of us will be on patreon on filter
unfiltered whatever that means it will
be nice to not have to do the exposing
government secrets it's just owning our
[ __ ] man yeah not working for the man
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's exciting man so
we're excited chris that you're coming
to uh join the crew king of this thing
in the wing yeah hang this thing in the
wing i appreciate it merch won't be
popping oh i know yeah i can't wait for
the and let me tell you something right
now this is just the beginning isn't it
it is isn't it this is the hustle yeah
there's so many things that we can
[ __ ] do and pretty much what chris
well we could end up doing a tour who
knows and uh uh infiltrate the
government
eventually we could raid the capital we
could infiltrate the government right
you are a conspiracy theorist we have
established that a lot of things are
conspiracy
yeah that's true i know you're trying to
see he was with me yeah no i'm not not
with you i'm not not with you yeah
please don't
so what else i'm saying is um you know
don't push me don't push don't push me
and songs we're going to sit in
different seats too yeah that's that's
one thing it's going to be a very
musical chairs kind of the fans are like
this yes
and the reason yeah and the reason why
it's different ceo thinks about things
so much he overthinks everything yeah
that's why we just like should i sit
here should i make him whatever you want
he's like well what do you think and
we're like i don't really think i don't
think about it i really don't give a
[ __ ] he's like but i've been thinking
about it all night
i guess
i couldn't sleep last night diagrams in
my car
how
collecting racks dude that's what it's
about man
stacking those [ __ ] racks to a
pyramid until it touches the sky
but with friends with friends
we're on top of the [ __ ] pyramids
like this dude yeah
gang gang
buzz buzz
soar
dude
the three of us
[ __ ] yeah dude
on your back
we'll need well you guys also sound
[ __ ] insane
okay you guys seem like uh the the
menendez brothers but if they were gary
vaynerchuk's sons and they killed him
trying to motivate him
that's amazing but what will we do king
it sting it or wing it no no leave the
same [ __ ] that we're done with oh wow
check out your tits check out the dad
tits daddy and those are dumb those are
daddy kids what the [ __ ] dude i swear to
god one day i was [ __ ] chilling and i
heard way in the distance god and i was
like what and i looked and there was a
film crew on my back
shooting the lord of the rings because
that [ __ ] is mountainous dude
what are you doing i think before he
joins he should have to answer to this
okay he sent in uh uh sync my ink maybe
a year yeah yeah okay cool hey guys just
got out of the shower don't have much
time obviously i'm a very busy man but i
heard about your new [ __ ] segment or
whatever it's called uh
describe your tattoo or whatever kind of
catchy thing you call it but um anyway i
figured i'd be the first entry uh yeah i
have tattoos and i got them right here
it's the and i got these by dr wu
who's a great artist uh and he did this
oh i saw this guy
that's because i got that tired eagle
joke that i have and then my special on
netflix man on fire
definitely regret doing this podcast
together you absolutely thought i would
oh yeah i remember that this part two i
got them at that age because i never
wanted to get them when i was younger
because i thought i would regret them
much like you guys
definitely regret doing this podcast
together you absolutely do i know you've
been good though now you gotta own it
you have to have to oh yeah right
exactly i said you regret it now i'm on
it because you're not doing it because
you you're doing it because of the money
and that's fine but it's a cash crap
unlike my podcast congratulations which
is straight from the soul and i don't
look for money
i do it because it's straight from the
salt ranking and right oh really what
about the rack pyramid that's just
happened a second ago that's for my soul
what about the ponzi
i'll tell you guys this dude what was
that guy asking about
what was that guy asking about it
chest here sting it yeah
uh should we do another confession well
this one's pretty good yeah yeah yeah
hopefully i found the video game guy but
that did take us down a cool path of
blockbuster and video games yeah that's
the idea the submission yeah yeah yeah
yeah the cool thing was you could go in
to get a movie and you might end up
getting a game you could go when they
would get a game you could be in there
for an hour your mom's weight is
furiously waiting in that car you get
forced to choose you're down like 10
seconds
you pick
drama you pick
murder
horror
it was like i loved
posters and you saw all the options it
was like you saw so many options
remember they didn't have the movie you
wanted like everyone rented you like ah
[ __ ] a good friend and you wouldn't
return totally yeah
and they'd be like let me check we do
have one i'm like [ __ ] yeah i'll take
that a thing of twizzlers and the freddy
krueger poster mom pay the guy with your
fake checked that was so good
yeah blockbuster was nice dude and one
thing that i don't like also about
regular uh streamers now you don't get
to see all the options blockbuster it
felt like you were choosing that's one
thing i noticed i was talking about this
on this past weekend but one thing i
noticed about being a blockbuster it
felt like you got to choose what you
wanted whereas with the streaming
service it feels like it just
observed it there's an algorithm and
they're like you you might like this i'm
like i like some other [ __ ] tonight man
right like blockbuster's like oh my god
there's all these options let me either
because there's options you don't even
think sometimes i always ate i'll walk
out with sleepless in seattle yeah
i got out one time
dude little giants and some [ __ ]
raisin ass and what's that move with
bobo and a little devil in it with those
little
bubbles
bubble and little devil no one watched
little giants ice box al bundy the coach
i didn't watch nothing but trouble
nothing but trouble god that was a good
movie
i missed that one in blockbuster dude
big trouble in little child watching
other [ __ ] whatever you're talking about
i didn't watch that that's a great movie
you didn't watch me
bro my dad my dad were rich you're
probably watching the lady because we
were not everywhere we were not with we
were not rich what would you want so uh
oh [ __ ] man
my dad was like he's like a [ __ ] you
know he's in a [ __ ] so he would call me
like he knows good [ __ ] i guess yeah but
he would like show me like old movies or
like that's boring like schindler's list
and stuff no that was a new movie your
dad would make you watch like the
godfather when you're seven no when i
got like he he took us to go see uh
what's that movie the citizen kane in
the theater like jesus christ yeah dude
but i was older at that point dude
teenage mutant ninja turtles oh it's the
movie
mc hammer vanilla eyes
go ninja go
go go go
go go i understand i saw all those but
let me tell you something dude talk
about the lost boys
and you can and you can fact check this
okay i'll destroy your damn movies we go
what'd you say no go ahead okay teenage
mutant ninja turtle i i was a huge fan
of the teenage mutant ninja who's your
favorite really bro mike angelo yes
and raphael was my favorite he's the
leader rashford
they are they're our leader splinter was
leader technically leonardo was leader
but leonardo was the blue one you know
it was a blue one and then raphael
raphael had that size
and raphael would have the swords no no
leonardo had the swords donald had the
staff donatello was the [ __ ]
intellect michelangelo had no numbers
hey i already know this
we sound like you don't no it sounds
like we're figuring this out together
you know leonardo wants to shut up i'll
break it i know you want to hear from a
guy who knows you know what he's doing
i know
leonardo was a guy with the swords
raphael had the size and he would be
like
yeah man three [ __ ] and then
michelangelo had the [ __ ] [ __ ]
and he loved the pizza the most loved
and then donatello had the staff and he
would [ __ ] build the robots and use
the brains of them yes we should bring
to the update and splinter was the boss
and then there was the there's splinter
shredder jones april i got the brain the
br krang bro the brain and right it's my
dick it's crank okay okay now let me
tell you something dude i love this show
i loved it so much and i feel like i
just proved it to you guys so yeah no no
let me tell you i didn't care about this
that's fine
you grew up different i think you know
what i'm saying so i was on cartoon i
love
i love the cartoon i loved it so much i
watched it all the time i love the
cartoon okay now saturday morning
cartoons okay now when the movie came
out guess what the movie came out on my
birthday it came out in march on my
birthday so i look at the screen i see
the tv you know it wasn't online you'd
have to see it on the thing i was like
whoa teach me new tutorials the movies
coming out on my birthday ma i want to
party at the theater for tangent ninja
turtles one so we [ __ ] did it okay
then a year goes by teenage mutant ninja
turtles two comes out on my [ __ ]
birthday you're lying about i'm not
lying that's why i said fact check it so
i say mom what did we do last year it's
because two years ago whatever it was
fire enough i said we're going to see
through the intros and those bad boys in
a half show for my birthday again at the
theater
so that was new journals too okay then
tease your ninja turtles three jumps out
jump on my [ __ ] birthday i'm not
lying dude and then i say well at that
point i was too old and i didn't go do
that because i was too old and i didn't
want to see the team but also part three
but how about that dude
you say the brain guy i correct that ass
by saying krang okay i hear that i only
do bunch with the right hand
and rat king was in there [ __ ]
yeah yeah hell yeah casey jones bro
birthday the trilogy the trilogy tissue
at the turtle birthday forget it yeah
that is lit march 22nd march 30th and
what was the other one i don't know
do you have the toys too
i mean they're not gonna come out they
can movies come out on a friday fridays
are different every year yeah yeah
that's true did you have the toys too
do i have the toys at the blimp i had
the blimp dude that you could carry the
blimp brendan shut the [ __ ] up
did i have the toys dude yeah i had
rocksteady i had bebop dude i had them
all dude
bebop had asperger's was it
one of them did
look at the [ __ ] dates dude
look at that citizen kane
after my birthday my mom said good idea
but probably not happening we don't have
the money you know
we went to the roller kingdom and
somebody one of my birthdays got
kidnapped actually some kid got
kidnapped by his stepdad for two or
three days yeah crazy did he hurt him no
no i don't think he heard her i just
wanted him yeah maybe just want to spend
quality time i don't know the kids maybe
not the cops beat the [ __ ] out of them
the kid no no
the kid was an idiot but he was nice i
mean nice you know
we weren't even that close it was a time
where you had to invite people it
invited like eight people see the you
knew the first three and then i said i
was like
now kids are under roblox you know what
i'm talking about i've heard about it
corey feldman was michelangelo uh in
those movies and i'm going [ __ ] off no
no he was the voice not the guy
yeah dude i know so much about ninja
turtles bro
he really does say something
all four voices though i don't i don't
i'm going to his caster on tuesday at
the whistle watch
studio one time leonardo yeah no yes
cory feldman corey phelps
these turtle boys don't get enough slack
dude my girl [ __ ] kristen tried to
make fun of me because i was like turtle
power turtles in a half shell and we
were watching i was trying to show you
we're watching recently bro i love the
teenage mutant ninja turtles don't get
it twisted
uh turtles in a half shell and they're
green age ninja turtles that she was
like green aged me ninja turtles you
[ __ ] up and i was like no i didn't
rewind it dude they say green age and
because so they can add it into teenage
and i was right let me [ __ ] blow your
mind i think i'm not going to be like no
it's called internal power by the way
and you can fact check this okay the guy
who made who created the jingle for
teenage mutant ninja turtles
is the guy who created two and a half
men
wow so he's balling
that's not that shocking it's not a wow
that's pretty yes it is guys
that guy's crushed that guy's crushing
chuckle chuck laurie
chuckles
don't cut him no slide he made the
teacher ninja turtles jingle dude he had
that van how crazy is that that's crazy
come on have you seen the new one i
don't know if it's that crazy i mean
he's successful in [ __ ] tv and
jingles dude that jingle is fine that
jingle is banging dude they should make
a rap song with it little brown should
do it you know how dope that would be
what would be a good what uh what else
is a good jingle
uh oh you know what it's really weird
about that
and i talked about this on
congratulations my podcast
like i need to say my podcast you know
what it is but
the [ __ ] dude uh
um chuck uh how how did they go from
teenage internals most bang and [ __ ]
jungle to two and a half men is just
men men men and women
no no that's terrible but it's still
banging at the end dude it's not banging
dude what did anyone watch the cartoon
to come home from school would be gummy
bears tail spin oh gummy bear
uh no dark winged dog
dark duck let's get dangerous my family
likes to watch drama like afternoon
dramas did you see tommy
title was lit too never watched gummy
bears bouncing from here and there
didn't watch it
in the heat of the night
oh that's the movie drama yeah
television
we would watch a lot of watch out in the
afternoon
when we got home from school the heat of
the night yeah sounds like boring dog no
boring what are you talking about you
know you could just see that and know
how many rings that's me and chappelle
on
player that's althea tibs right there at
the bottom in the middle oh she and i
saw her having breakfast one day and
got erection my mind you did what yeah
huh when probably about
two and a half years ago god what a
different life we grew up with oh he
thought it was so good we grew up with
lit ass we should do it and here's the
saddest part i know you guys are
thinking about something else already no
no
i'm listening
this man in the middle is carol o'connor
who also did archie bunker yeah yeah
yeah his son was the guy on the left oh
he got far left and he overdosed and
passed away oh yeah yeah you could tell
that guys
was also in far right american fighters
uh but he was also in another tv show
he's also hercules did you say far right
sorry
you seemed fine man
you didn't hold up a unique flag while
you were gone
um
but that guy worked on uh what's the
phone on the far right no dude you
talking about gladiators did somebody
[Laughter]
just a second
uh ago good
you ordered a colorless coffee american
gladiators is that american gladiators i
said that
five minutes ago
you didn't say yeah i did no you thought
you did no i did dude
he's also hercules all right that ain't
hercules that's hercules on the far
right
it's hercules i looked it up too didn't
see it i think that's joe millionaire
too right yeah no kevin are you sure
yeah
yes we used to get together at a place
called reno's in the valley and watch uh
just me and like old friends that you
don't even know but like yeah thank you
you know how you have like live
different lives yeah
we won't know each other in five years
but yep uh we used to go to this pizza
place in the valley called at reno and
we were called reno's and we would
horrible names
what was the guy's name that's not the
same guy nick it's the guy's name no
that's not him don't they look similar
am i crazy i know who is completely by
the way do you know what he is right now
gay man
he's far right yeah yeah he is he's hit
yeah he's got two right wings and um
he's got a lot of good ideas and so
what'd he say he's got a lot of good
ideas so so no so we used to go to
reno's and watch that uh [ __ ] joe
millionaire every every week bro it was
a huge show remember how big it was i
don't actually know i don't know
he was a construction worker and he had
a chance at a million dollars or a woman
right no they thought they thought he
was a millionaire he was a yeah and he
was just a construction worker and at
the end he's like guess what just
constructed worker and they're like you
[ __ ] liar who did did anybody get
into jerry springer when it was first
kicking off before i thought it was fake
no not really really not really i i saw
it but i was never in your dad will let
you watch it
my dad looks like gary springer by the
way yeah he does joe millionaire's back
and it's it's a one actual rich guy and
one poor guy and they live together and
then and they're both not white and they
both have to vote they're both not white
i know they're both not white they're
both not white look it up they're both
transgender it's woke as [ __ ] and
they're not white and we know love is
blind is back to darnell millionaires
incredible darnell millionaires
[Music]
that got us
grabbing my dick and i'm touching myself
all right okay
oh they are both white wow oh yeah
that's on hulu okay okay
they couldn't be more white
they're vampires
dude these guys are on westwood
boulevard every day
right now that picture right there is
the worst picture i've seen
just all of it together in two things
when you should have took that picture
for a king this thing in the way that is
the worst promo picture of all time no
no you know what it is oh [ __ ] what is
it oh [ __ ] the new movie with greg
kinnier and uh courtney cox and lisa
kudrow
it's the worst
no
nobody's going to see this movie and i
don't know why they didn't know the
theaters i don't shining veil
it's called shining veil looks bad and
the [ __ ] word for it is awful i'm out
and jennifer lowe is in a new movie
who's that jennifer lopez
look at that [ __ ] who's going to go
look at that oh how awful that is
shining valley what does volley mean i
don't want to see that it's a mexican i
don't want to see that i know but what
does it even mean though hey bali
hey valley did you hit that ball back
and forth
you're shining very volume back and
forth shining value
i'm out
it sounds like a two connectors oh oh
bro drake is awesome that's amazing is
awesome yeah and and you know courtney
cox is you know she's a beast she yeah
you heard they bob saggett they think he
hid his head on something somebody broke
they're full of [ __ ] they think somebody
hit him with something the doctor said
the only way to get conspiracy theorists
coming out no i'm judging maybe it's
true i'm just saying they're saying the
only way to get those fractures on the
front and back
with he said the doctor said he'd have
to be either beaten by a bat in the head
or fall from 30 stories or head banging
in a really small room no i don't think
so
or putting on something real tight on
your head hmm isn't it crazy the worst
doctor and the family well you know
what's weird is the family doesn't want
this to get out on his head
are you done with med school um
no i snuck in
we just saw what happens when you have a
steel toe boot closes on if something
you have tight on your head dude
so
i mean if that's true
this isn't conspiracy this came out in
the autopsy you're just saying [ __ ] you
read you saw somewhere no this is
autopsy isn't everyone and they are
suing to not release they don't want it
getting out
so here's what then here's what could
have happened this is high position i
can't wait for this
this could have been a
man
or woman
was around him late at night and abused
him
kimmy gibbler
[Music]
[Laughter]
no not not her no not chemicals
spitballing ideas there yeah
definitely didn't just hit his head on
the bathtub and then went to
sleep they had facial fractures horrible
fractures
in the back of the head oh this is like
that owl when that hole is attacked i
know whoa
i'm talking about stairs
the documentary the stairs then at the
end they tell you stairs dude it's
called the staircase hey hey hey hey
documentary the stairs
hold on you know what's how am i right
yeah you got the reference right i get
the main part right but it's hot but you
got it but you got it but all right yes
because if it was called the stairs you
know that nobody would have watched it
the staircase sounds nice yes [ __ ]
dude the stairs
sound scary might as well just call it
some stairs yeah i'm in yeah me too
actually that's banging yeah some stairs
[ __ ] yeah dude actually the prequel some
stairs people under the diagonal yes
um does that he did he do it first well
then the crazy part is at the end like
oh also another wife of his got thrown
down the stairs a couple years earlier
yeah dude you don't want to hear what i
think there's like three wives
do you want to hear what i think about
this we don't have a choice yeah you
don't
look
i think maybe he did do it or maybe he
didn't do it i don't know but what i do
feel like okay
they didn't prove that he did it
so it's crazy that he's in jail to me
but it's very clear he kind of did it
right you just think it's
it it's just a coincidence all three
wives died falling downstairs two wives
i don't think so it's wives if you
pluralize it but i don't think so but
wait is sylvester stallone playing him
is that why he came up no i just thought
he looked like him yeah
[Laughter]
it was
all done again
um
all right well i don't think the guy uh
i think the owl thing just seemed crazy
because i don't know if a bird would
throw someone downstairs because how do
they even know to do it i mean we've
seen we've seen the eagles throw [ __ ]
sheep down mountains
yeah think about it good point use your
[ __ ] hand don't say we i haven't seen
that that's amazing yeah i can't believe
we uh eagle grab a a
goat pick it up and then carry it so
high and throw it down a mountain
at the bottom and the wing dude that's
so cool that's it dude that should be
our mo that should be our uh that should
be in the intro yeah
even i couldn't they eat them because
they fall down the mountain and die and
they eat them what
nature nature is crazy huh oh they kill
it on the mountain they use it pick it
up and then drop it oh
and these goats are like ah [ __ ]
and they get real stiff when they fall
see because those you know those goats
that climb side of the mountain which
make no sense mountain goats yeah dog
ibexes so there we go they're called
either the goats like dude come on be
cool be cool be cool be cool be cool
and we're going for a ride
and then he just kind of floats with
them and then roughs them up oh it's
called tenderizing the meat fellas
and then he left him jerking off all the
way down and then look at this
and that goat's like well i'm dead now
the eagles cool stories are you [ __ ]
or is he feeding his family he's feeding
himself what if he just used him as a
toilet that would be so disrespectful
dude how scary would be you see in the
[ __ ] shadow of that thing you're a
little baby goat yeah dude what if you
just wrote a note into his fur
why'd you say that bro that made me sad
i'm trying to educate you dude but it's
not it's not this is a comedy podcast
and you made me sad barely what did he
say
what did who say what did brennan say he
said what if like a kid goat watched it
or something no i'm saying what if
you're a baby goat and you saw you just
see the shadow and your mom was like hey
man you see a [ __ ] shadow it's game
over we got to get moving yeah but they
don't speak english
but in their language come on dude dude
they do the short king get them in here
which one they're both short
don't act like you don't have three
short guys that work for you you have
three yeah
just coincidence
is it really yeah i don't know [ __ ]
short people right now
you don't have that if you're if you're
this tall if you're under this height
you can work here that's one of those
you can't ride a ride at disneyland you
can work at thick boys dude how did we
gloss over that man getting
killed by that shark so clearly
well i told you what happened like yeah
clearly so then i just breathed past
you're like yeah whatever of course he
died we talked about video game for 20
minutes and that
gave his life up for nature and we just
i'm a little bit upset that every time i
tried to say i know
somebody talks over it and there i just
got it out anyway
leo's a bad camera man though
yeah that he was a bad cameraman but no
please don't no stop stop on the street
how many tattoos does the guy who say i
know you have australians if you are
australian and you don't have tattoos
you you're not australian no you know
how many [ __ ] tattoos australians
have
uh-uh 15 at least you think so how much
none of them are small
it's always like the entire 100 thousand
way more how many more people are six
million how many people are in australia
oh [ __ ] way more than guess how many
before we lose yes okay this is going to
be insane you guessed first brendan okay
people are in it um
80 million no
no
too much yeah
too much you go i'm going to go for the
continental australia united states is
what 600 million uh 750. yeah i don't
think so i said 80 million
anyway and we heard that part and i'm
going to do probably price is right
i'm going to do australia yeah that's
what i'm talking about
i would go with
spit it out dude no take your time 19
million okay oh wow that's um very let's
play ball all right if the price is
right i'm gonna go with one so if you
guys went over i will
one there's one person how many how many
is this
i want to know chris is real good what's
your real guess so we had nine times 80
35.
well price is right rules yeah wins 19.
he won anyway he went anyway he went in
now 25.6 now
but it's getting more and more it could
be 35 million at this point i love it
there we have way more in california
i know now that's a place we should go
do a tour at australia
and we're in the united states and it's
so odd also off camera it's it's odd how
much theo says we should do a tour in
australia that's the fourth time you set
and i don't disagree i love australia
love it it's fine it's fine and i will
go with you i mean we'll do a [ __ ]
king in this thing in the wing
murder tour dude we'll call it the
murder tour we will call it the [ __ ]
murder tour worldwide why did that guy
just die there all right can't get over
it he can't go
that shark's doing shark [ __ ] though you
know he can't be mad dude you go in the
sea that's kind of what could happen we
need that garden dining option yeah is
that it nick that's it we ran past time
all right kids as you're listening this
i am in sacramento tonight talk about
that patreon thing and then talk about
the thing remember just right
now get ready
fresh my memory get ready starting in
march
we got two episodes exclusively on
patreon with just theo von crystalia and
myself we'll drop the link and then
you're gonna get the link you see the
promo on our instagrams even theo's
gonna blast it out thank god so it's
gonna be on patreon two episodes a month
make sure you subscribe to that and then
also we still be doing the two free ones
on youtube and all the rest of the stuff
we can get two
fire podcast a month on patreon with
diovan crystalia bee shop king the sting
and the wing yes dude when will it start
though we don't know yet in march in
march yeah it's always next week i know
yeah i know but it's also in two weeks
and three weeks and it's our birthday
month so it'll be cool so the first week
of march it'll be probably regular
episodes yeah first week of march be
regular episode after the second week of
march it'll be a patreon yep oh wow
guns so uh uh
yeah yeah go ahead that's it i got
rockford illinois actually tonight
i'll be in rockford illinois
and then tomorrow night i'll be in
chicago illinois
i think that's correct or tomorrow night
or something anyway i'm in rockford in
chicago like right now so come on out
there 25th february 26th still there uh
sacramento is a punchline tonight friday
saturday 30 takes left by time this
comes out to be sold out not a big deal
uh nashville tennessee theo stomping
ground is march 10th through the 12th at
zany's
chicago march 24th through 26th phoenix
just went live april 14th through the
16th that's it kids i'm doing uh
crystallia and friends april 8th through
the 9th irvine so
it might be uh yeah go get tickets
there's probably a few left at this
point and i'm doing rockford illinois
february 25 and
tomorrow night
or tonight if you listen to this on
friday oh good good good
and saturday
i'm in chicago theater so
it's the king the sting and the wing
we'll be on patreon in march make sure
you subscribe to it kids love you
[Music]
back with the crew we got stevie weeby
eric griffin brendan do2 yeah you know
how we do it so just tune in for the
laughs theo said that he was on his way
but ran out of gas
stevie weeby used to wrestle down at paw
way
now he only finished boys in the hallway
this ain't the greatest show on earth
and what you call that eric griffin with
them he the nate dogger podcast
get a whole crew sick it's the king and
the stick what up chin what up nick
stevie we be eric griffin just walked in
and got it lit you can't forget about
brendan he still need everything dick
dick they still got the bees in the trap
trapping
still the king in the sting so quit
asking if you know then you know it's a
cat's thing
[Music]
with the crew we got stevie weeby eric
griffin brendan theo too yeah you know
how we do it so just tune in for the
laughs theo said that he was on his way
but ran out of gas
[Music]
[Applause]
king and the sting
you